تعتبر الكرنب عنصرًا أساسيًا
في المطبخ الجنوبي، لكن معظم الناس
يعتقدون أنها شيء يجب
طهيه لفترة طويلة، وأنا هنا
لأخبرك أنهم لا يفعلون ذلك، وسأريكم
خدعة لتحضيرها  لقد حظيت
كايلا اللذيذة بلحظتها، وأعتقد أن الوقت قد حان
لكي تحصل الكرنب الأخضر على بعض الحب
تمامًا مثل الكرنب الأخضر الغني
بالألياف ولكنه يحتوي على سعرات حرارية أقل، فهو يحتوي على نسبة
أعلى من البروتين وأعلى في
فيتامين ك،
لذلك قمت بإزالة الجذع السميك في
مركز الكرنب الأخضر
وسأقوم بتقطيعها إلى شرائح، لذا إذا قمت بتقطيعها إلى شرائح
رفيعة جدًا، فسوف تصبح
طرية بشكل أسرع بكثير لجعلها
لذيذة والتي أعتقد أنها كذلك بالفعل
ولكننا سنمنحها القليل من الحب الإضافي.
سأضيف قليلًا من الملح فقط
[موسيقى]
الملح سيتبلها ولكنه
سيساعد أيضًا في سحب بعض
السائل الموجود بداخلها ويساعد في جعلها طرية،
لذا هذا هو الجزء الممتع الذي
سترميه  الكرنب الأخضر مع
الملح ولكن أيضًا قم بعصره
وتدليكه، يمكنك القيام بذلك مع
أي ورق أخضر داكن لتحويله
إلى شيء أكثر طراوة ولذيذًا
من مجرد تقطيعه، يمكنك أن
ترى كم هي داكنة ولامعة، كما
أنها تشعر أيضًا  أصبحت أكثر ليونة، وبهذه الطريقة
تعرف أنك حصلت على الخضراوات اللذيذة والطرية،
ويمكنك تناولها الآن كما هي
مع عصرة من عصير الليمون
والقليل من زيت الزيتون أو يمكنك
رميها مع صلصة الخل وتقديمها
كطبق جانبي.  طبق
الكثير من النكهة لدرجة أنني أستطيع تناول وعاء كامل
من هذا